you follow good
anyone else
yes sir what if a writer is attempting
to create a story
where nothing much happens where people
don't change
they don't have any epiphanies they
struggle and are frustrated and nothing
is resolved
more reflection of the real world the
real world
yes sir the real [ __ ] world
first of all you write a screenplay
without conflict or crisis you'll boil
your audience to tears
secondly nothing happens in the world
are you out of your [ __ ] mind
people are murdered every day there's
genocide war corruption every [ __ ]
day somewhere in the world
somebody sacrifices his life to save
somebody else every [ __ ] day someone
somewhere
takes a conscious decision to destroy
someone else
people find love people lose it for
christ's sake
a child watches a mother beaten to death
on the steps of a church
someone goes hungry somebody else
betrays his best friend
for a woman if you can't find that stuff
in life
then you my friend don't know crap about
life
and why the [ __ ] are you wasting my two
precious hours
with your movie i don't have any use for
it
i don't have any bloody use for it
okay thanks
mr mckee yes i'm the guy
you yelled at this morning
i need more i'm the one who thought
things didn't happen in life
right okay nice to see you i need to
talk
mr mckee my even standing here is very
scary i don't mean people well
but what you said this morning shook me
to the bone what you said was bigger
than my screenwriting choices
it was about my choices as a human being
please
yeah well you know
i could sure use a drink my friend
but a little fantastic and fleeting and
out of reach
then what happens
that's the end of the book i wanted to
present it simply
without big character arcs or
sensationalizing the story
i wanted to show flowers as god's
miracles i want to show that orley never
saw
the blooming ghost orchid it was about
disappointment
is he
that's not a movie you got to go back
put in the drama i can't go back i i've
i've got
pages of false starts and wrong
approaches i
i i'm way past my deadline tell your
secret
the last act makes a film
while them in the end you gotta hit you
can have flaws
problems but wow them in the end
and you've got a hit find an ending
but don't cheat and don't you dare bring
in a deus ex machina
your characters must change
and the change must come from them
do that and you'll be fine
you promise
mr mckee
you've taken my course before my brother
did my twin brother donald
he's the one who got me to come between
the screenway
julius and philip epstein
wrote casablanca ah they were twins
you mentioned that in class finest
screenplay ever written